major Garrett is at the White House
where the Trump administration is
warning North Korea of a massive
military response to any threat major
good morning good morning the sense that
both nations are on a collision course
is quite simply unmistakable North Korea
keeps moving toward a nuclear weapon
capable of reaching the continental
United States and in a statement
released here at the White House
yesterday President Trump said all
assets are at his disposal including the
vast US nuclear arsenal
North Korea's successful test of an
alleged hydrogen bomb far more powerful
than the atomic bombs at the dawn of the
nuclear age brought a stern warning from
defense secretary James matters
any threat to the United States or its
territories including Guam or our allies
will be met with a massive military
response a response both effective and
overwhelming mattis spoke after an
emergency national security meeting at
the White House and outlined every
military option we are not looking to
the total annihilation of a country
namely North Korea before the meeting
President Trump attended church for the
National Day of Prayer for hurricane
Harvey and was asked if he would attack
North Korea
[Music]
South Carolina Republican Lindsey Graham
described the conflict to come if
economic pressure or diplomacy failed
I'm assuming we drop one bomb he fires
at South Korea and maybe Japan let me
tell you how the war ends it ends with
his utter destruction thousands of
people could be killed or maimed mr.
Trump said North Korean dictator Kim
Jong hoon has become a great threat and
embarrassment to China he added
South Korea's talk of appeasement will
not work this behavior is completely
unacceptable the administration is for
the time being promising to intensify
economic pressure the White House is
also considering punishing those who
trade with North Korea anybody that
wants to do trade or business with them
would be prevented from doing trade or
business with us the next level of US
sanctions could focus on large
state-owned banks or businesses in China
that deal frequently with North Korea
and the threat of cutting off US trade
with China over the dispute with North
Korea could affect both nations Jeff
last year more than a trillion dollars
in trade between the US and China major
Garrett thank you